[Music]
pretty shot there the capital welcome
back to cbs mornings we are learning new
details this morning on the negotiations
to pass president biden's ambitious
agenda congressional democrats are
facing a self-imposed deadline at the
end of the month and we have new
reporting on how the size of the social
safety net package could be reduced and
reduced significantly nancy cordes is at
the white house for us this is big news
nancy good morning to you
good morning to you tony and you know
anytime you need to slash a 3.5 trillion
dollar spending bill nearly in half
there are going to be some big ticket
items that have to go and now after a
series of meetings at the white house
yesterday we have a better sense of what
those items are going to be the top
democratic priority that appears to be
out is a provision that would have made
community college tuition free for
everybody now that's a painful cut for
some progressives no question but it's a
sacrifice they appear to be willing to
make to get the price tag down another
proposal that is most likely going to
take a hit is guaranteed paid family
leave which could get reduced from a
proposed 12 weeks to let's say as low as
four weeks but a medicare expansion
universal pre-k and a one-year extension
of the child tax credit will likely be
preserved now one serious sticking point
at this point is a proposed measure to
combat climate change west virginia
moderate democrat joe manchin told cbs
news quote the carbon tax is not on the
board at all right now but other
democrats are disputing that this is a
measure that would reward companies for
investing in renewable energy and
reducing emissions
all of these changes are being made to
try to win over mansion and one other
democratic holdout and if democrats can
reach an internal agreement by let's say
the end of this week perhaps into the
middle of next week then they'll be able
to pass not just this big social
spending bill but that one trillion
dollar infrastructure bill that's been
waiting in the wings as well nate
still so much at stake financially with
the ripple effect that can affect us all
nancy thank you so much